5 vous pourrez bientôt lundi je pense
revenir vous balader sur le célèbre
canal saint-martin à sec depuis deux
mois il va en effet être remise en eau
ce week-end y aura pris un petit coup de
jeune après un grand nettoyage d'automne
récit du chômage du canal saint-martin
avec xavier grimaud et jean-marc garde
jamais un chômage n'aura donné autant de
travail en deux mois de mise à sec près
de 200 personnes ont travaillé sur
quatre chantiers différents du canal
saint-martin en premier lieu nettoyées
quatre mille mètres cubes de vase et
divers objets hétéroclites ont été
évacués 35 à 10 15 vélos huit motos deux
coffres forts vide une grenade défensive
un fusil à pompe et même deux obus il
faudra attendre l'an 2000 pour refaire
une telle moisson au fond du canal moins
spectaculaire mais tout aussi importants
les travaux de maçonnerie des berges et
de rénovation des cinq écluses du
parcours enfin le chantier le plus
coûteux 18 millions de francs pour la
partie souterraine de la voie d'eau sous
le boulevard richard lenoir treize mille
mètres cubes de ciment ont été injectés
dans les assises des voûtes à raison d'1
point d'injection tous les douze mètres
s'est rendu compte en 1985 que
des assises de
notre ouvrage et
risquer de manquer de stabilité du fait
de décompression de terrain
ces endroits là au total la toilette du
canal saint martin aura coûté 25
millions de francs les premières vannes
ont été réouvertes au bassin de la
villette
mais la remise en eau des 6 km
provisoirement à sécher se fera
progressivement le canal saint martin ne
retrouvera son allure habituelle qu'à la
fin du week-end